what's that belief nation we are giving
away one free ticket to my workshop in
September on how to make money as a
thought leader here in Toronto Canada
and this video I'm gonna explain how you
can win your free ticket
now how this workshop in Toronto and we
did the first one in May and it was an
amazing life-changing experience with
the people who showed up and it was such
a blast that I thought I have to do this
again and said we're doing it again in
September from the 3rd to the 5th here
in Toronto this workshop isn't for every
entrepreneur it's for the people who
want to take the ideas that they have in
their head and make money from it as a
thought leader as an expert so if you
want to make money from brain deals from
writing the book from coaching from
consulting from advertising basically do
what I do but do it in your industry I'm
gonna teach people how to do it day one
is all about knowledge transfer so I'm
gonna be going through everything that I
do to build my business I'm gonna be
breaking down every single revenue
stream from the brand deals and book
deals and advertising all of that stuff
and then how you can optimize your
revenue stream and start making money as
a thought leader there too and it's just
knowledge dump it's taking everything
that's in here everything that I do
right now in a in a 20-18 environment of
how imposts in a YouTube and Instagram
and all the networks my workflow my
process and dumping it from here into
here into your head right there now as
valuable as day one is I think the real
value comes from day two and day three
day two is about the experience and so
with day two you're gonna work with
myself and my team to actually make
content it really frustrated me in going
to workshops that a lot of people got a
lot of information but there's no follow
up there's no action taken and my goal
with this is for me for three days to
get my hooks my hooks my hooks into you
so that I want to see how far I can take
you in those three days so not just give
you energy and ideas but to actually
experience something together so day -
we're making content together so you're
gonna work with myself and members of my
team we're gonna be making videos for
YouTube we're gonna be making videos for
Instagram for snapchat we're gonna be
making content and we're gonna be
guiding you the
highlight Lisa Lee I think for me the
highlight is I'm gonna work with you
one-on-one and we're gonna make a video
for you telling your story I'm gonna be
coaching you and then my team is gonna
edit it together for you
so that you do not have any excuses for
not coming out of this session we're not
coming out of September with quality
videos telling your story and I'm gonna
be sitting there behind the camera well
I got my camera guy filming that I'm
sitting there kind of directing you
along the way giving you feedback saying
okay do this again fix it say it like
this try this tell me why you're not
pushing hard enough here because I
really want you to be able to get the
thing that's in here and the thing
that's in here out to the world so you
can make a difference it's not just
about knowledge transfer for your
audience is about energy transfer if you
want to win it's about getting the
energy out and so that's that's the
value of day two and then the three is
an optional ticket not everybody's
coming for day three but whoever wins
this free contest you're coming to day
three day three is mastermind in the
morning and so whatever question you
have whatever business challenge you
have right now you want me to look over
your Instagram feed you want me to check
out your YouTube videos you want to talk
about different revenue streams anything
whatever you're dealing with right now
that's the time to come up bring it up
we're gonna do a little mini group
mastermind this is a this is a limited
session though guys it's 10 to 15 people
maximum this is not a massive huge
stadium event I want to keep it personal
because you're getting my personal time
I'm shutting down everything that I do
I'm not posting I'm not doing anything
but being with you guys and these are
three full days so the morning day 3 is
mastermind and in the afternoon we're
doing one-on-ones and you can use that
one-on-one either to interview me for
your channel if you want to have me on
your YouTube channel your podcast your
IG live Facebook live whatever you want
to do or just some one-on-one coach you
with me so if you want me to one-on-one
help you with a specific problem you let
me know and we use that time there's
also some bonus activities with people
on my team and some of the people that
are coming that that's gonna be pretty
fun anyway it's a it's a life-changing
experience it's really hard to explain
how valuable it was for the people who
came out I think a lot of people come in
thinking yeah I'm just gonna get a bunch
of strategies but it's just
way way way so much more than that when
you can get people together who are all
similarly aligned you all want to have
an impact you all want to make a
difference through what you got up in
here and you're in a supportive
collective and then you're not just
getting the knowledge but you're
actually doing the work I can't stress
how important that is like we're
actually gonna be doing the content
creation together how much that sets you
up for success to then go home and
continue to execute and then start
building a business build an empire
create results start impacting the lives
of the people around you I think your
purpose comes from your pain and I think
you've got something great inside you
that could really help a lot of people
and it's so frustrating that that you're
not getting the results that you sit in
there without the YouTube subscribers
without the Instagram audience without
the newsletter list but it's not
actually that difficult to be able to
get off and do it I just want to be a
resource and guide you and help you I
kind of wish that I had this when I was
getting started so I'm providing it for
you anyway
that's what's happening three days in
September September third to fifth here
in Toronto we're gonna have a ton of fun
together there's the event and then
we're having dinners and a whole bunch
of fun but there's a free ticket this is
amazing so one of my fans a hardcore
member wrote to me on email and she
wrote this Evan thank you for all you do
I really get a lot from it I believe I
want to pay it forward somehow I think
you have a class or event coming in
September in Toronto correct I tried to
look for it but couldn't find anything I
would like to sponsor slash pay for
someone to go to do it or would you have
other event coming up
I love given to someone else please let
me know and I saw this email like wow
that's pretty cool
had an impact on somebody and believe
nation to the point that she wanted to
sponsor one of you guys to come to this
event for free so here's what we're
gonna do it's a full three day pass what
I want you to do is make a video
explaining why you should be the person
who gets the free ticket email that
video to free at Evan Carmichael com
we'll make the deadline August 3rd
one week from today August third you got
one week to make this video the best
ones we're gonna save we're gonna show
her and she's gonna be the one that
actually picks the winner so give your
best message I'm so looking forward to
having one of you join us in Toronto as
a special lucky guest so thank you guys
so much for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
good luck and a special extra bit of
thank-you and gratitude to our surprise
donor I really appreciate you it means a
lot to me and I'm sure the person who
wins I will make sure my commitment I
will make sure that the person that you
are sponsoring they're gonna have a
life-changing experience in Toronto in
September thank you guys take care
terrific world domination
honey Empire right I'm grateful I
understand why I'm here I think because
I am so open I wanted to think I see
it's a bloody brief life all of you have
the potential for enormous success if
you want to know what Gary Vee DJ Khalid
Oprah and others know about empire
building that most people miss check out
the link in the description for a free
bonus video